Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Denise RQ
(Musica)
Questo pezzo potrebbe continuare
in tantissimi modi diversi,
in effetti ci sto ancora lavorando.
È uno dei pezzi che ho scritto
un po' di anni fa
e continua a tornare,
ma ancora non ho scelto,
sto ancora cercando, cercando qualcosa.
Avete presente i jeans?
Non i jeans qualunque,
sto parlando dei jeans, l'idea dei jeans,
il sogno di qualsiasi persona,
trovare quel paio perfetto di jeans,
quello fatto per noi, quello
per cui quando entri in un negozio
dici oggi li trovo e allora prendi,
te ne provi venti paia
e ogni volta è la stessa storia,
non li troverai mai.
Personalmente sono convinta
che la mia idea di jeans
forse esiste solo in astratto.
Ecco, quei jeans che puoi fare tutto,
passare il rastrello nel giardino
a piedi scalzi.
Questa foto avrà settant'anni
e mi sa che lei sta ancora
cercando quel paio di jeans, mi sa, sì.
Insomma, scrivere musica è un po' così,
c'è, ci deve essere da qualche parte
ma mi sa che non riesci a vederlo
e allora tenti,
attraverso la musica,
di tradurlo, trasportarlo
e ogni tanto entrare in contatto
e avere qualche fugace visione.
Ecco, per me scrivere musica
è cercare, è più qualcosa del genere.
Ne avverto la presenza
e mi manca, una sorta di fame.
In famiglia si è sempre detto
che vai al ristorante,
riempi lo stomaco, colmi
quella fame, ma c'è un'altra fame,
che è quella intellettuale,
dello spirito e per quella
c'è la musica, l'arte, si va
nei musei, i ristoranti dello spirito.
Questa ricerca, questa continua tensione
verso questo ideale
è diventata per me, negli anni,
una vera e propria ispirazione.
Gli antichi la chiamavano
la musa, Calliope, Euterpe,
"Cantami o diva" scrive Omero.
Questa musa veniva
quando voleva, liberamente,
a trovare l'artista e lo ispirava,
lo elevava nel suo mondo
e l'artista si faceva canale.
A volte capita di cogliere delle visioni,
come grappoli di note.
Non capita sempre
quando stai a tavolino, sei pronto,
lì col pentagramma; spesso
capita quando stai correndo
verso la metro, vai di corsa
all'appuntamento di un lavoro
e improvvisamente
senti che c'è una melodia:
no, questa non me la devo perdere!
E allora cerchi un posto dove scriverlo
e l'unico posto è il biglietto
che è tutto stampato,
c'è poco spazio - veramente l'ho fatto -
e tracci giù le righe, un mini pentagramma
e poi non hai l'orecchio assoluto,
che nota sarà?
Allora stai lì nell'angolo
e cerchi di cantare.
Per fortuna oggi i telefoni
hanno quei registratori fantastici,
però questo per dire
che chi è alla ricerca,
nel campo della creatività,
dell'arte, non perde
mai l'occasione di entrare
in contatto con lei.
Ma non è che si fa sempre viva,
certe volte la aspetti, ascolti, niente.
Giorni, mesi...
niente, l'ispirazione non viene.
È inaffidabile.
E allora che cosa fare?
Aspettare per una visita?
Parlando di piccole incursioni della musa,
un famosissimo chitarrista inglese
racconta in un'intervista
di vari anni fa come una sera,
nella sua stanza di albergo,
tornato dopo una lunga serata
di festeggiamenti, sotto l'effetto
dell'alcool e di chissà
quale altra sostanza
- erano gli anni Sessanta -
si mette sul letto,
comincia a suonare la chitarra,
accanto al letto c'era uno
dei primi registratori a nastro
e canta finché non crolla
dal sonno sul letto;
la mattina dopo si sveglia
e si è totalmente dimenticato
di quello che è successo
la notte, però vede e nota
che sul comodino il registratore
aveva continuato a girare
tutta la notte, il nastro era finito.
Incuriosito riavvolge il nastro
fin dall'inizio, spinge PLAY
e sente per i primi due minuti
- aveva un totale blackout,
nessuna memoria -
sente se stesso che canticchia
e accenna sulla chitarra
delle note; era lui.
Le note che sente accennate
alla chitarra sono così:
[Musica]
I can't get no satisfaction...
Io questo lo chiamo
un bel regalo della musa,
una bellissima incursione notturna,
stiamo parlando di Keith Richards.
Questo era il grappolo
di note che è sceso,
ha preso il controllo su di lui,
ha fatto sì che spingesse REC,
che poi è diventato uno dei più grandi
successi della storia del rock:
(I can't get no) satisfaction.
Continua l'intervista e dice:
dopo quei primi due minuti
il nastro ha continuato a fare PLAY
ed erano 40 minuti di me
che russavo amabilmente
e dice, continua e conclude
che sta ancora aspettando
un altro di questi regali.
Ora, non è che basta
avere queste tre note.
Insomma, sfido chiunque a trovare
sul nastro quelle note,
che sono abbastanza semplici,
e a tirarne fuori questo.
Quindi sono qui per parlare del lavoro
che c'è intorno a questa prima scintilla,
che possiamo chiamare
musa, ispirazione, come volete:
ognuno ha la propria fonte,
ma c'è tutto un contesto
che possiamo noi attivamente costruire
e specialmente quando la musa è assente
possiamo partire dal mondo terreno.
Se la musa non viene andiamo noi da lei
ed eleviamo quello che abbiamo,
quello che siamo, elementi concreti.
Ci guardiamo intorno e se riusciamo
e ci dedichiamo abbastanza
possiamo raggiungere ugualmente,
a mio avviso,
quello stato di ispirazione,
facendo un'offerta
di quello che si è, della nostra umanità,
l'offerta alla musa.
Non sto parlando di dar fuoco a strumenti.
Lui è Jimi Hendrix,
lui può qualsiasi cosa.
Sto parlando di qualità umane
che quando entrano in contatto
con il lavoro ispirato possono
generare dei bellissimi risultati.
Sono tre le qualità
che noto spesso nei lavori
che mi piacciono di grandi artisti,
primo fra i quali il gesto.
La gestualità umana si può tradurre
in arte, in comunicazione.
Vedete i direttori d'orchestra
come con il gesto
riescono a modellare
un'intera sonorità, del tutto personale.
Vedete in pittura come dei singoli gesti,
delle intenzioni si traducono in concetti.
Se dovessi immaginare la musica
di questo la immaginerei
graffiante, acuta, non lo so,
forse la scena della doccia in Psyco,
dei gesti immediati.
Qualunque cosa, però
mi ispira molto quando vedo
che un essere umano
ha portato sé, un suo elemento
e l'ha offerto all'arte.
Vediamo il gesto in musica.
Questa è la prima pagina manoscritta
della quinta sinfonia di Beethoven,
il primo movimento.
Nel cerchio vedete ingrandite una pausa,
tre note seguite da una nota lunga.
Questo è l'inizio ed è tutto un gesto.
Il genio di Beethoven
ha saputo individuare
il potenziale dietro a questo gesto
e lo ripete,
Seconda qualità: la durata.
Quando ascoltate un pezzo,
scrivete o suonate,
interpretate, notate l'importanza
delle proporzioni temporali.
Quanto portare avanti un discorso:
può essere la cosa più bella del mondo,
ma tutto deve essere equilibrato.
Quanto durano i silenzi
e questa architettura del tempo,
non quello oggettivo,
quello che calcolano gli orologi,
ma il tempo interiore,
quello che decidiamo noi,
perché fare musica è anche questo,
creare un mondo temporale parallelo.
Allora io questo lo noto
nelle più grandi opere,
questa capacità di avere
il controllo del tempo.
Ultimo, cosa c'è di più umano,
di terreno, di naturale del contrasto.
I contrasti sono linfa vitale
per il movimento e per l'interesse.
L'accostamento improbabile
di cose: improvvisamente un
movimento lentissimo e poi,
tutto ad un tratto superconcitato.
Accostamenti impossibili creano movimento.
Immaginate un paesaggio
sonoro, aspro, duro
e improvvisamente la comparsa,
dopo un po' di tempo,
di una dolcissima e innocente melodia.
Quanto può essere valorizzato
da quello che precede?
Questo quadro di Tiziano,
Amor sacro e amor profano,
ci mostra il contrasto, la coesistenza
del terreno e del divino,
del sacro, messi in comunicazione diretta.
Vedete le caratteristiche diverse
di quello che l'umano può portare.
Questi gioielli, questi tessuti, i ricami
e come il divino si mostra dato, perfetto.
Nella musica, nell'arte,
nella vita in generale
penso che la coesistenza
e la comunicazione,
in proporzione diverse,
di questi due elementi,
astratto e concreto,
ispirazione e duro lavoro,
siano i due elementi principali.
Al centro vediamo un amorino, forse Cupido
che rimesta le acque,
sottolineando il messaggio
"Abbiamo bisogno di tutti e due".
Pensando a questa sala mi sono chiesta
come potrebbe risuonare questa sala,
se volessi applicare
un po' di questi filtri umani
e cercare di elevare il contesto
e farlo risuonare in musica.
Penserei a degli accordi ampi, grandi,
che risuonano e poi percepirei
tante piccole presenze,
pensieri, vite animate
al centro e quindi suonerei
delle note leggere, che si muovono.
Ognuno di voi risuonerebbe
attraverso queste note.
E perché non far risuonare
questa sala con ognuno di voi,
semplicemente sussurrando il proprio nome.
Quindi vi chiedo di partecipare
adesso, possiamo provare,
a semplicemente sussurrare il proprio nome
quando sentirete l'esigenza di farlo.
(Musica)
(Applausi)